so should this video be called maybe it
isn't
yeah i mean i'm a philosopher right so
i'm not going to give you really
definite
definite answers i'm just going to be
saying it's super hard to know but i
think in general you know some
philosophers think it's just not
possible at all for ai to be conscious
and i don't think that at all i think
any sensible theory of consciousness
basically doesn't tie it to anything
essential to human beings it's not like
you have to have this wet brain or
anything like that
mark it is brilliant to have you back on
computer file here we are again yeah i'm
glad to be back here it's been a while
hasn't it it has and and
look let's get out of the way straight
away there'll be some people out there
who don't want to watch humanities it is
really relevant for this right i think
this is going to be really interesting
because there's this strong link between
philosophy philosophy of mind ai and
computer science so hopefully we can
cover all of that fantastic and so we've
done this recent video about a certain
chat bot effectively that's yeah you
know uh yeah it claims somebody claims
sentience and we went through a
technical side of that i think that when
it was claimed this might be sentient
they weren't worrying about the
definition they were really trying there
were lots of people saying in the
comments on the technical video that
perhaps the that mike wasn't qualified
to answer some of the more philosophical
questions so here we go i can try
so one of the things that um has come up
again and again
is is this linked back to the turing
test right yes so let's just can we just
pray see what the turin test is and
whether it's still relevant yeah so this
is the idea from from alan turing that
basically we can test for
intelligence for artificial intelligence
by effectively just doing a blind test
we have a uh a human interpreter who's
going to be asking questions and getting
answers back and maybe one way of
setting it up is you have one bunch of
answers coming from a human respondent
another bunch of answers coming from an
artificial respondent and the
interpreter has to try and work out is
one of them human is one of them a
computer if she can't tell the
difference between them then we're
basically gonna have to say that yeah
this artificial system is intelligence
or at least that's turing's idea
computing has moved on since uh turing's
time
it has but you could still think there's
something to this idea i mean
effectively it's saying if you can't be
distinguished from an intelligent human
then you might for all intents and
purposes be an intelligent system but
there is this sense that what we're
looking at doing there is tricking right
if i'm trying to design a system to pass
the turing test then i'm thinking how
can i trick this human interpreter into
just passing me
and you know tricking somebody into
passing you
isn't the same thing as actually being
intelligent okay and the other thing
that kind of cropped up quite a bit in
the kind of uh comment section on the
previous video was about this idea of
kind of persistent memory is is that
relevant because people have amnesia and
they're still sentient right absolutely
yes so in philosophy when we're talking
about personal identity the idea of the
continuance of memory and other
conscious features that's really
important but that's more about being
the same person over time so why am i
the same person i was yesterday or when
i was a 10 year old well a lot of that
is to do with my my memories and my
continuance of of consciousness
but that's not the same thing as being
intelligent or being sentient or even
being conscious
and maybe you can have a system or even
a person who is conscious at a
particular time and then suffers some
you know
terrible
mental catastrophe and then loses
consciousness and then maybe regains
consciousness they're still conscious
and intelligent and sentient at those
times
even if they're not necessarily the same
person over time one interesting thing
is we named the last video and literally
this was the name of the video no it's
not sentient i mean
can we actually say that for sure
it's super hard to know i mean there are
different things going on here there's
intelligence
which i think you've got to say maybe
some computer systems are intelligent at
least at certain things there's
sentience and there's consciousness and
they're slightly different than
intelligence
to be sentient or to be conscious it
isn't just to
give intelligent answers in response to
questions but it's to feel something
right when you are conscious of
something if you're conscious of like
the way the wind feels right now i'm
feeling it and it's a big big leap to
say that any kind of artificial system
any kind of ai is really feeling the
stuff so even if it's saying i'm really
enjoying this conversation
is it really feeling the enjoyment in
the way that you know a conscious human
would we've done a few videos quite a
series of videos on ai safety and the
idea of the worry what happens when
artificial general intelligence happens
and if it happens before we even know it
would we even know that this system is
sentient oh that's a real tricky one so
there's this kind of prior question that
i always think there which is how do i
know that you're sentient how do i know
that you're conscious so i know that i'm
conscious because i feel it right i'm
feeling the wind i'm feeling like a
toothache or whatever but i never get to
get inside your head and feel that but i
assume that you feel all the same things
as me
and that's roughly because
i may be thinking to myself why do you
behave the way you do so why is it that
when you know you feel the cold you
start shivering and put warm clothes on
and when someone treads on your foot you
say ow and do all those things that i
would
well in some ways maybe i can't say a
hundred percent for sure but it seems
the best explanation of why you behave
that way is because you're feeling
roughly the same things that i do so
that's inference the best explanation
the best explanation of why you act in
the way you do in them circumstances is
because you're feeling roughly the same
kind of things as me because you're a
conscious person that's why you behave
the way you do
that kind of argument that kind of way
of getting knowledge of consciousness
isn't going to be so smooth with
artificial systems because they don't
behave the way we do right they don't
react to the cold or to toothache or
whatever in the way that we do so
that's not saying that we can't know
they're conscious
it just makes it much much harder it's a
bit like meeting an alien intelligence
or something we don't know how it's
going to perceive things we don't know
it's going to yeah i guess so yeah
that's it and you know you kind of when
you kind of
on on tv right when when creatures uh
you know when we encounter aliens in in
sci-fi
the kind of default is if they kind of
look a bit like us and behave a bit like
us the kind of default assumption is
well they feel roughly the same kind of
stuff that we do
but when it's kind of robots or if it
just doesn't look or behave like us it's
much much harder to make those
inferences so that's not saying that
those creatures those ai systems or
whatever aren't sentient that they
aren't conscious it just makes it harder
for us to know is it a spectrum is there
kind of like a sliding scale of this
consciousness absolutely yes so you know
just looking at the things that we do
think are conscious right so all the
different animals from from small to
large from less complex to more complex
uh pretty much
very few philosophers nowadays think
that there's this sharp cut off between
you know humans who are conscious and
all the other ones who aren't conscious
that you know you you kind of assume
that your your dogs and your cats they
they feel
they feel pain they feel attachment they
feel emotions um you know that's why you
definitely shouldn't be cruel to them
but they probably don't have the same
kind of detailed life plans career plans
and stuff that humans have
so you know there is this scale of
consciousness probably right down to
real basic sentience i mean in some
sense plants are sentient of the sun
because they they turn towards it and
they reach for it
you know so when we're talking about
artificial intelligence artificial
sentience yeah that whole spectrum is
out there so you know we're not saying
that any ai has kind of human level
consciousness but maybe
now or maybe at some point in the future
we're talking about these basic forms of
of of sentience you know maybe just a an
ai system thinking
i don't want to get turned off tonight
or you know i don't want the power to go
off or whatever consciousness is in
effect
computing a function right the the most
prominent
theory philosophical theory of
consciousness is functionalism that's
basically saying to be to be conscious
your brain has to compute this function
and this idea ties in really closely
with turing machines and one of the
things about turing machines is we don't
really care too much about how they're
implemented whether it's with ones and
zeros or however it's done you can do it
with regime
registered machines or bits of tape
whatever it doesn't really matter the
important thing is the function that's
being computed
and that's what a lot of philosophers
think now about the mind and the brain
it's not exactly how the brain works
that's important it's the function that
it's being computed so if you took any
kind of system any kind of machine that
computes the same function as a human
brain
it would have to be conscious in exactly
the same way that human brains are that
you know they would feel the same thing
it's just a very very very complicated
function
well i was thinking that yeah because
our ones and zeros our cells and our
kind of like logic gates our neurons and
but we are a machine in some sense yeah
in some sense we're a machine yeah
computing this function it's just a very
very nuanced complicated one uh you know
it's not the kind of thing that you
could easily write down even just
writing it down in terms of like input
output rules or anything like that it's
it's super super super difficult
i'm a computer scientist i'm a
philosopher i'm a logician you run your
own channel so tell us a bit about that
what do you do okay so it's called attic
philosophy because i'm up in my attic
talking philosophy and logic so if
you're interested in this kind of stuff
you want to see some more philosophy
some more logic relate to computer
science
come and take a look